now that you've got the files and folder
set up that you'll be working with how
are you going to actually write the CSS
to define your framework I suggested
using a 12 column grid because it's
really easy to create all the columns
that you need but what else do you think
you'll need to define well you need to
create a CSS class that includes a row
of 100% page with a CSS class for a row
of 112 of the page width remember 12
years coming from the number of columns
what we only need to create one column
class of 1/12 of the page width to
define our columns will we need to
create multiple columns of everything
between 1 over 12 and 12 over 12 page
widths that means we'll need to create a
column class for 1 over 12 page widths
one for two over 12 page widths 1 for 3
over 12 page widths one for four over
twelve page widths and so on or will we
only need to create columns of 2 over 12
3 over 12 and 4 over 12 page widths to
create our framework oh and by the way
the reason I put these dots here is
because when you're writing CSS you'll
need to identify that something is a
class by putting a dot in front of it so
it's good to get used to that notation
now think about this question and when
you're done check all that apply